in 2009 steve jobs would call out amazon
for not reporting the unit sales of
their kindle e-readers
arguing that the only reason amazon
wasn't reporting unit sales
was because they weren't selling very
many nine years later
apple would announce that they were
going to stop reporting iphone unit
sales
given that smartphones have basically
reached their final form and virtually
everyone who wants one and can afford
one already has one
it's not surprising that iphone sales
have been declining over the past
several years
what may be surprising though is hearing
the apple car will be apple's next
major hit when you take a look at the
automotive industry
one of the first points i stick out is
the raw size of the industry
no other industry is able to boast such
high unit sales at such a high price
in fact the average price paid for a new
car in the u.s
cost forty thousand dollars in december
of 2020
and even with the pandemic drop 14.471
million cars were sold in the us in 2020
alone
this is extremely beneficial to apple as
not only is there a lot of demand
but consumers are already willing to pay
large amounts for their vehicles
when apple introduced the iphone
spending 500 for a phone was unheard of
apple had to wait years for the market
itself to grow before they could
capitalize on the popularity of the
iphone
with cars on the other hand there's
already millions of consumers who
purchase luxury automobiles worth
upwards of one hundred thousand dollars
every single year another major
advantage for apple is that the
automotive market doesn't have any
monopolistic players
even the biggest automobile
manufacturers only control a mere
fraction of the overall industry
as of 2019 toyota was the only company
that even had a market share in the
double digits
coming in at 10.24 volkswagen came in
second place boasting 7.59
market share and everyone else is about
5 or
under considering this apple won't have
to deal with someone like amazon and
e-commerce or google in search engines
not to mention apple has no intention of
competing against the major
players they're not trying to become the
next toyota nor are they trying to
become the next tesla
you see apple has become the master of
controlling extremely profitable niche
markets
and they have no reason to divert from
what they excel in
just listen to what tim cook said at his
congressional hearing
our goal is the best not the most
in fact we don't have a dominant share
in
any market or in any product category
where we do business
keeping this in mind the apple car will
likely come in at about 75 000
like experts expect and apple will
target a high-end niche market
given the depth and breadth of the
automotive industry this approach will
be easier than
ever before something else to keep in
mind is that apple is well aware of what
they're good at
and what they're not good at something
that they're not good at is
manufacturing vehicles and scaling of
production
consequently they have no issues
admitting this up front and looking for
manufacturing partners
scaling up manufacturing has been one of
the biggest struggles for tesla
so it's extremely wise that apple is
planning on outsourcing this from the
very beginning
considering all of this plus the power
of apple branding
it's not hard to see how apple can
quickly go into a niche player selling a
few hundred thousand cars
every year over the long term a
realistic target for apple may be about
one million cars per year
which is a little more than one percent
global market share to put that in
perspective
mercedes-benz or the daimler group
achieved annual sales of 2.84 million
cars in 2020
so annual sales of 1 million for apple
would only be about a third of what
legacy luxury automakers are achieving
at 75 000 a car apple would be able to
generate approximately 75 billion
annually in revenue according to apple's
q for 2020 earnings report
they were pulling in approximately 260
billion annually
thus the addition of an automotive
business would grow apple's overall
revenue by nearly 30 percent
but this is where most automotive
companies run into a problem
no vehicles have high selling prices it
also costs quite a bit to actually
produce and market a vehicle
thus most automakers have extremely
meager profit margins
for instance before the recent decline
luxury automakers like bmw were now
profiting about five to seven percent
if we call apple's net profit five
percent to be conservative apple would
pull in about 3.75 billion
annually now that's still quite a bit of
money
but it's nowhere near 75 billion dollars
moreover
apple already generates 50 to 60 billion
every single year in net profit
so their entrance into the automotive
business would only increase their
profit by about seven percent
considering this though it won't be too
terribly difficult for apple to capture
a niche portion of the car industry
and generate enormous revenues not very
much of that will actually translate to
apple's bottom line
but then why is apple even bothering
with cars
well the answer is that the apple car is
not an automotive play
it's actually a service display and that
brings me into phase 2
of the apple car project once apple has
cracked into the car market by
leveraging manufacturing partners and
their own brand image
apple will focus on milking high margin
service sales in apple's case
the first major service opportunity is
of course autonomous software
for many years now tesla has been
selling self-driving software as a
one-time purchase
and that makes sense as self-driving
software is still in beta development
however elon musk already revealed that
tesla's working on a monthly
subscription plan for self-driving
software
and once fsd is more refined it's likely
that tesla
as well as other software software
providers will shift to subscription
only models
this makes much more sense as customers
are constantly receiving updates
even years after their purchase not to
mention a subscription model will be
significantly more profitable and
reliable for automakers
so companies will strongly prefer this
option over the long term
and this is where apple will really
shine but
how much will they even charge for such
a service well
we can estimate this based on what tesla
will likely charge
currently you have to pay tesla ten
thousand dollars if you want to buy full
self driving
up front tesla definitely does not want
to cannibalize these one time sales by
offering a super cheap subscription
so it's very unlikely that we'll see a
price like 100 per month like many are
hoping for
here's the thing if tesla only charges
100 per month for an ffd subscription
it would take over 8 years for each user
to pay the full 10k
and no one would buy the 10k option thus
it's crucial that the upfront option is
more desirable over the long term
if we say that the upfront option is
cheaper if you use it for five years or
more
then the monthly subscription would have
to cost at least 166.67
if we say that the upfront option is
cheaper if you use it for three years or
more
then the monthly subscription would have
to cost at least 277.78 cents
considering this it's likely that the
monthly subscription option will cost at
least 200 to 250 dollars per month
and that's when fsd costs just 10 000
elon musk has previously tweeted that
the value of full fsd
is in excess of one hundred thousand
dollars so over the long term
i have a feeling that tesla will charge
at least three hundred dollars per month
and possibly as much as five hundred
dollars per month and considering that
we're talking about apple here
the amount they would charge would
likely be on the higher end of the
spectrum
at five hundred dollars per month i know
that's extremely expensive
as that comes out to six thousand
dollars every single year
here's the thing though the price of fsd
is not based on how much people are
willing to pay for it
but rather how much automakers can make
by just keeping the technology to
themselves
tesla expects that using a tesla as a
robo taxi would generate 30 000
gross profit every single year so it
makes absolutely no sense to sell you
this technology for 10 or 20 grand
the average person of course cannot
afford this and that's why tesla is
planning to eventually fully shift away
from the consumer car market
and focus on just robo taxis for apple
on the other hand
their niche market may very well be
interested in a premium 500
per month self-driving subscription
people who are buying a 75 000
car are obviously doing really well or
at least i hope they are as that would
otherwise be a really dumb purchase
if we assume that the average apple car
buyer is making four to seven times the
price for the car
on an annual basis we get a salary range
of about three hundred thousand dollars
to five hundred thousand dollars
now dave ramsey would advise that a car
should be less than ten percent of your
gross annual income
meaning that ideally apple car buyers
are making seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars per year
or more but we'll call it an average of
four hundred thousand dollars per year
to be conservative
given that the average person works two
thousand hours every single year
this means that our apple car buyer is
making roughly two hundred dollars per
hour
so though five hundred dollars per month
for self-driving may be a lot to you
and me for a vice president or a local
business owner
if getting apple self-driving
subscription means that they can save
more than two and a half hours per month
it's absolutely worth it the average
american spends 10 hours and 50 minutes
on a car
every single week that's the same as
over 40 hours every month
if the average apple car buyer has a
similar commute time every month
they're only spending about 10 to 15
dollars per hour of self-driving service
and instead of driving they could be
attending a meeting or closing a deal
with a client
making hundreds of dollars during that
time at the end of 2019
experts estimated that 30 to 40 of tesla
buyers also bought autopilot
but really that number is likely heavily
skewed it's likely that amongst tesla
model x and s buyers
the takeaway for fsd is closer to 50 to
60 percent
meanwhile the tick rate amongst model 3
and y virus is likely closer to 10 to 20
if we say that the take rate for fsd is
50 amongst apple car buyers
out of 1 million car sales every year
500 000 customers will spring for the
fsd option
in the us the average time that a
consumer keeps a car is about six years
assuming that luxury car buyers switch
cars more frequently will say that the
average apple car buyer keeps their car
for about five years
that means that apple would have about
2.5 million monthly subscribers
after they are done growing and that's
excluding the used car market
at 500 per month that translates to 1.25
billion
revenue per month and 15 billion revenue
per year
if we take a look at apple's financial
report we'll see that their gross margin
on their services
is 67 meaning that apple can enjoy gross
profit of about 10 billion
per year from self-driving software
subscriptions we'll say that the 3.75
billion
apple profits from actual car sales goes
towards all of the operating expenses of
fsd
as well as taxes that means that apple
could not profit about 10 billion
every year just from their car business
but we're still not done
what about infotainment the app store
brought in 64 billion
revenue in 2020. apple takes a 30 cut of
all the revenue that comes in through
the app store
meaning that that itself is about 20
billion in profit
when you're in a self-driving apple car
it's likely that you'll be listening to
up on music
or watching apple tv or playing games
offered on the apple cars app store
and all of this is just billions of
dollars more for apple
also what about repairs i'm sure apple
is going to make their cars hard to
repair by herself
if we add another 5 billion onto apple's
bottom line from car repairs and other
car services
we get a total net profit of 15 billion
dollars per year
at their current p e ratio of 33.4
apple's car business would add a little
over 500 billion
onto apple's market cap and that's why
the apple car would be a monetary
masterpiece
did you guys realize the massive
potential of the automotive services
business
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for fully
autonomous cars
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you